bard runs three early college programs
one is simon's rock which is a
residential program in great barrington
the other are two public high schools
here in New York we're in New York you
enter after the eighth grade so you do 9
10 11 12 the end of the 12th grade you
get a junior college anaa degree at
simon's rock you enter after a tenth
grade and then you do in two years in a
degree even stay for four year bard ba
because I went to college at sixteen
people think this is autobiographical it
isn't I went to college 16 that's when I
graduated high school I wasn't really
prepared socially I was thrown in at the
university of chicago which was a
terrific experience for me with students
who are largely older their group of us
who were 16 chicago did specialize in
taking younger applicants often and but
wasn't because of my experience it was
in my experience in the classroom seeing
young people coming college at 18 who
had lost at least two years of their
schooling and been turned off by by bad
schooling to learning and they had grown
up there were adolescent they were fully
mature they were independent you know
they were independent consumers that
independent social life they were
sexually active already laid in in high
school they had matured they were
treated by society as young adult except
in the school in school they're treated
as big children and the fact is that I
thought it's a good experiment to see
whether a large portion of the
college-bound population would be better
off starting college early so at simon's
rock we accumulate a lot of data that
showed it actually works and so in the
public sector in New York we have public
schools not charter schools to do this
it's been fantastically successful in my
view for fully half of American high
school students schooling should end the
end of the 10th grade we should have a
system which has elementary and
secondary should be six years of
elementary in four years of high school
no middle school no junior high school
and get
people out let them start their
education as adults at age 16
well we have the over ninety percent
graduation rate and over nine percent go
on to further schooling and they're
completely by class and race diverse in
New York our populations mirror the
demography of the city of New York
what's important is that they're with
their own age group when they start
college the older programs 50 40 years
ago put a 16 year old into a college
population was average age with 19 and
that's a problem here they're together
as a group when they go to four-year
college either for two or three years or
four years at the end of the twelfth
grade when they have an a a degree they
actually enter as 18 year olds with
other 18 year old there may have be
advanced in their credits but there with
the same age group so what we do is
we've created a system by which the the
young person is never out of touch with
his or her own peer group